All right, so our Q and A today some questions that came in question number one. I'm using
I am pro wave probably every morning for hpilora is the frequency of this program going to kill
the hpilora in my stomach and is this enough treatment for hpilora as we know hpilora destroys
stomach acid is the bacteria is this bacteria create ammonia that can cause bad breath if yes what's
the solution of HCl pepsin and digestive enzymes do not work okay so hpilora it itself doesn't
necessarily destroy stomach acid it's actually because a person has low stomach acid that
is one major reason why we get hpilora overgrowth in the stomach now wherever hpilora is a bacteria
he look a he look a bactore pylora and it's part of our normal flora but the main strain that causes
that ends up in overgrowth in our stomach and can go through the stomach walls and can get into the
bloodstream is one of the top five causes of heart disease it's a major player in many cancers it's
the number one cause of stomach cancer worldwide at part of the cause of overgrowth has to do with
the decrease of stomach acid hcl hcl is created by the gastric cells it's it needs B vitamins in order to
be created and it helps also the creation of hcl helps keep the balance of pH in the blood as well
so it's all part of our buffering system so what do you do when you have hpilora overgrowth
well rutting the ion pro wave rutting the frequencies on the rife can be very beneficial
so rife frequencies are most beneficial to kill bacteria livid organisms virus
bold and kills ourselves it's you know the the the rife is not the perfect tool for detoxing heavy
metal i am pro wave can help with that but you need a key later also with that also what's really good
with hpilora is burberry so burberry is a is a um uh herbal compound that tends to be really good
to help kill hpilora when you take hcl and digestive enzymes uh for hpilora you're not trying to kill the
hpilora with the with the hcl and digestive enzymes you're trying to just bring balance of the
low pH the acidity back to the stomach to help um break down carbohydrates in the stomach that's
what hcl does and bring that pH balance back down so hpilora i can thrive so hcl is necessarily killing
uh hpilora in the gut but it's helping bring that balance back now hpilora is important i write a lot
about it i have a number of blogs and web pages about it because it's so prevalent um one
um some articles that came out a number of years ago said that the majority of the population have
an hpilora overgrowth um and the one doctor who actually put it on the mark uh came out and said
that hpilora is the cause of stomach ulcers and he was so ridiculed that he um gave himself an
hpilora infection by by consuming hpilora bacteria gave himself an an overgrowth of hpilora infection
and caused ulcers in his own body to prove that hpilora is the cause of ulcers crazy but the guy
was like listen to me uh scientific world so much uh going on today that the so much of the scientific
world uh doctors are not being listened to so he was in that same situation back in the
1980s when he proved that so is the question is the iron pro wave is the rife enough to kill hpilora
i'd say probably sometimes um if you have a bad hpilora overgrowth you'll get stomach ulcers
then you can't take hcl i would go with burberry i would go with um some other uh products like gastro
miocin that has bismuth in it to help calm that stomach down uh first um and then uh when your
stomach starts to heal the ulcers start to heal then i would add hcl and digestive enzymes but
continue on the burmarine um i take burmarine at least three four five times a week um because
at number one is a great cancer killer but it's a it is the killer of hpilora and my dad had a
major heart attack at 56 57 years old um and again hpilora is in the top five causes of heart
and vascular disease so hpilora is something that everybody should really be you know treating
on a regular basis so um i would suggest burmarine if that whoever asks this question is not taking
it another question what should and i gf1 level b at a 75 year old um uh was blood test uh to be okay
i heard it's not good might as 25 so yeah 25 is certainly low for somebody 75 here's a chart
you could pull this up online i just pulled this right off of uh of google i did address this question
last week as well uh your i gf1 levels go down as you get older somebody 75 you would think
looking at this chart um somebody at 75 should be about 55 probably years is 25 would i be concerned
about that well if i wasn't fighting cancer if i did not have cancer yeah i might be concerned
about that and then there's some things that you could do and take to help increase i gf1 levels um
most of the weightlifting community exercise community they're trying to increase i gf1 levels because
if you're trying to build muscle and trying to bulk up you want really high i gf1 levels uh if you're
trying to fight cancer you want lower i gf1 levels so more so um looking at whether the 25 is too low
or too high or what i'd look at maybe what else is going on physiologically that's causing such a low
i gf1 level i'd want to do some investigation of that we should probably have a conversation about that
and get some more data what's going on because yeah that is that is certainly low and i'd have to
do some investigation to see what else could be causing low i gf1 levels no it could be your benefit it
could help slow cancer growth having low i gf1 level so maybe it's not at our best interest to try to
get them um elevated at this point but it also would be might be in our best interest to look at maybe
some causes of why it's so low another one i was reading metformin reduces potentially i'm
copying a pasting these from people's emails so sorry about the miss spells i changed some of the
words but metformin is a drug that is for diabetes it lowers blood glucose levels um there's some
use of metformin for cancer patients because it's reducing glucose levels and whatever we could
reduce glucose levels there could be benefits especially if the person's cancer is mainly fed through
glycolysis so there are some prescribing physicians that will prescribe metformin as if a person has
diabetes to cancer patients as an off label use of the drug to help slow cancer don't so is that
always a good thing to do for a cancer patient not necessarily here i just pulled a quick chart
of different side effects of metformin and you go well i would deal with the indigestion and the
decrease appetite and the diarrhea the abdominal discomfort and the heart palpitations and the
taste disturbances not that i would get all those symptoms but i would deal that if deal with that if
it's going to slow my cancer down and i would agree these are side effects that you could deal with if
it's going to slow your cancer down um but you'd want to look at your blood glucose levels as well
and you know if in fact it does decrease igf1 levels and your on metformin well that might be why your
igf1 levels are low so you do want to look at side effects of drugs before you start using them
and you want to look at what the off label purpose of that drug is so for a cancer patient the off
label purpose of using metformin is to decrease blood glucose levels and if your blood glucose
level is already low because you're eating a really good diet and you're not consuming a lot of
carbohydrates and you are testing your blood glucose level and 12 over fast of blood glucose is in
the 70s or 80s then it might not be in your best interest to use metformin but if your 12 over fast
of blood glucose level is still 111 then metformin might be a good addition to add to get your those
blood glucose levels down to a healthier number another question I know there are blood tests
besides tumor marker tests that show circulating cells in the blood okay so first of all the tumor
marker tests do not are not showing and I don't know that this person is making that comment but
let's clarify tumor marker tests are measuring a specific enzyme that tumors some tumors
give off they're not showing circulating tumor cells so I would like to do one and I'm assuming
they're saying a blood test showing circulating tumor cells because the next part of this question in
December since I have not had such a blood test on which lab should one use bioseph lab is in
San Diego are doing liquid biopsy blood tests I don't know which tests they do so personally I don't
see a big value at all in doing a test for circulating tumor cells so circulating tumor cell is going to take
a couple of miles of blood out of your blood and they're going to measure circulating tumor cells
well just because I don't have you know any circulating tumor cells in those two files of blood
does not mean that I don't have or haven't had circulating tumor cells within the time that I
started to develop cancer then finally was diagnosed with cancer and now I'm going through a treatment
of cancer so you just have to assume that you have circulating tumor cells so remember what a
circulating tumor cells the primary site of cancer here like in this picture will give off
break off little cells those are circulating tumor cells now they're not yet
replicating so they're not yet growing metastatic tumor somewhere but that's what they're looking for
some place to set up home and raise a family somewhere outside of the primary tumor site that's
what metastasis is so a metastatic tumor is so let's say this primary tumor is breast tumor it's a
breast cancer it's given off circulating tumor cells even before you were ever diagnosed with cancer
so remember a cancer mass has to be three million cells large for it to even be picked up on a CT scan
and it's certainly not palpable at that time you still can't even feel it so it has it has given
off started to give me off circulating tumor cells maybe at a thousand cells large maybe at 10,000
cells large and it's certainly given off a whole lot by the time you were ever diagnosed so you have
circulating tumor cells throughout your body they you may or may not have some in the sample of blood that
was drawn that's why I say it does not give us a whole lot of value telling us that you know you go
get a sample of blood drawn and you don't have any circulating tumor cells besides the fact that it
gives us no value to how aggressive your cancer is or whether there's metastasis anywhere whether you
have circulating tumor cells in those two vials of blood that were drawn that doesn't give us any so
I'm all for doing testing if it's going to give us you know some indications some objective data
that's going to make us change the way we treat the patient I believe that you should just assume
that you have circulating tumor cells or have had circulating tumor cells that are trying to
develop metastasis and you should then do things to help prevent that metastasis to occur and that
is things that are that you like using the rife like changing your diet like taking supplements that
are going to stimulate an immune response because that's the only thing that's going to keep
circulating tumor cells from forming a metastasis not chemotherapy chemotherapy chemotherapy is going
to mainly target cancer cells that are already in rapid replication to circulating tumor cells that
are just dormant somewhere in your liver like in this picture right here that have yet to start to
replicate are not going to be affected by any conventional methods chemotherapies not going to touch
them radiation isn't going to touch them unless you radiated that spot right there which there's no
way that you would because there's no way that you know that you have a certain you know any
circulating tumor cell that is settled down in your liver it won't measure that this test will
measure that so I have never pushed in any of my lectures or any of my writing that we should do
circulated tumor cell tests to me it's it's a waste of money. Next question can protocell be coming
out my pores causing odor yes it can so it is remember protocell is an oxidizing agent and any
oxidizing agent can give your body an odor you people notice that when they do chemo and certainly
you could notice that with protocell that is actually a good thing is that your body is detoxing it
so doing sodas can be very helpful to help expedite that and help detox your body that way so think
about doing sodas think about doing your ion pro wave programs and continue to do the rife I would say
that is actually data about the it's a good thing. Next any suggestions for dealing with constant
nausea and heartburn from the radiation to the esophagus so radiation causes burning causes
wound formation and basically ulceration so here's some ideas that could really help
alo juice number one so alo juice can be really healing we don't have alo juice in our store you
can find that in a local health food store alo juice could be could be really healing you could
actually take alo from an alo plant slitted open take all the inside goo out of it and you could
eat a teaspoon of that maybe you know even a couple times a day it could be really really healing
liquid CBD drops liquid CBD small away that so that it could actually coat your throat and get
all the way down to the esophagus can be very helpful too lavender water you can make your own with some
fresh lavender put it in a water bottle and you can make your own lavender water add that to your water
can be helpful coconut oil can help coat your squamous cells of your esophagus that could be very
helpful juicing cabbage cabbage so that is can be very helpful to the stomach lining in the
esophageal lining making cabbage juice also potato juice I didn't have it in here but potato juice
can be very healing to that too so if you if you could get a juicer and juice cabbages juice potatoes
you can add some other things to it for flavor add some apple to flavor would be good too
fed you greek tea fed you greek leaves can be very healing to that area as well
banana can be healing and honey can be healing we'd always suggest a pure honey that is not
pasteurized local honey that's not pasteurized so those are some really good things to heal these
are also be good things you go back to the question up here with the stomach if you have a stomach
ulcer too those are some really good things to help heal that too one of the other things too I
mean the pain is coming from radiation from the esophagus but but you don't know about the
possible issues with with any bacteria overgrowth that now is taking advantage of that wound there too
so think about probiotics too the other thing you might want to that I might suggest with any
stomach ulcers or ulcers in the esophagus is opening up any capsules supplements that you're
taking opening them up and if you open them up the capsules themselves won't be irritating on the esophagus
and dump the contents in in you know some apple juice or something or apple sauce or something
like that could be beneficial too but these would be all really really helpful I'd really want to
hear some feedback from the person who asked this question so if you try these things can you please
email me how you're doing with that because I want to know some feedback about that
that next one of your thoughts on my MRI results now this person I did not see your MRI results so
all I know is the MRI from yesterday did not show a demon indicating the fractures have healed
again I just copied and pasted this exact question so I would like to see what the radiologist said
about the MRI results to give a more perfect answer to this so if you could email me that
the not the MRI itself but the radiology report and I'll gladly get on the phone and talk to you
about that so we can get more detail on that so I'm answering that correctly correctly okay so again
we're going to open it up for questions please unmute yourself so I can hear you and
because I'm allowing everybody to unmute themselves I can't unmute you so Dr. Connor I have a question
the protocol that we talked about